you guys i wish i could spend my time
telling you both how incredible this
movie is and how i want the sequel right
here right now but i only have six
minutes with you but it's so good um but
quickly zendaya i have to ask you about
another absolute spectacle
that dress
what was the inspiration for the look
that shook the world
uh the inspiration was dune um it's
interesting because i had um
i had seen
the bodice come down the runway i think
in 2019 which was like right after we
shot the movie so my head was already
thinking to the premiere
when we shot it you know um and i'd seen
it go down the runway and i'd ask then i
asked why i was like do you think that
they would do like a dress version of
this for the premiere one day and he was
like absolutely we can make that happen
and so it's been kind of in the works
there's been sketches for like several
years at this point
um and then finally we were able to uh
to to make it a reality you know but it
was you know i had molding and castings
made of my body and then they created
this uh gorgeous piece of art that was
uh supposed to be i guess essentially
just a reflection of this film hopefully
something that felt like
dune a little bit also the necklace
you know just a little something on top
was it 93 carats what what's the
presentation
it was i i don't i don't keep it you
know it definitely goes goes back to its
its rightful home at burglary but uh
please nobody robbed me yeah i don't
have it it's not mine um but yeah i know
it was absolutely gorgeous so uh yeah
and i felt very very
cool we had been talking about looks for
a while yeah
yeah i knew you had that i think like
six months ago yeah
as you said in 2019 but i remember
asking
the day like six months ago you have
something already for venice it's just
like yes it's already in the works yeah
guys the the fashion combination of
youtube i mean it's been my whole
weekend right it's been all i've been
doing this weekend
well no but i feel like i feel like
dynamic like zenday has been doing this
for
years and crushing it let me tell you
the leg cross you invented your own red
carpet pose well thank you well thank
you thank you um listen i was excited to
do it with with this guy because i i
know he appreciates and understands
what a duo well again the movie is so
good and uh it it's just incredible
it's made from a tooth of shyhalud
the great sandwich
this will be a great honor for you to
die holding it
you obviously got close making it what
was it like kind of surviving the desert
together
i was you know we had already been in
the desert maybe three four weeks and i
was just super grateful as in day i got
there i was getting along with everyone
i don't want to sound ageist but it was
great to have uh
you know
uh someone
knows of the same age
and then also her assistant darnell we
just had a we had a really great time
and obviously on set took material as
seriously as required but then offset we
were you know losing our minds
yeah comes the day i gotta give you a
belated happy birthday thank you thank
you the big two five you know what i'm
saying the quarter century very sweet
post from tom what was it like to see
the post and i noticed you commented
calling now
no it's i mean i i am yeah i was it was
sweet i guess i don't know
um um yeah no i um i appreciated you
know the love that i got from my loved
ones and then also from you know the
world it was i felt incredibly loved and
grateful for for all of that so you know
i have no complaints it was a great
birthday and now i'm here so
not bad
and now you're in a movie that's
probably gonna get probably get a couple
oscar noms i guess i'm not in the mood
today
move
what's mood to do with it you fight when
the necessity arises no matter the mood
now fight
when i tell you i left the theater
saying i want the sequel um a are you
guys ready for the oscars buzz and b
when are we getting the sequel
man we're i think we're grateful for the
experience of doing it and this is a
great thrill now especially in this
time of global uncertainty we're very
lucky to be able to get out there and
talk about this movie so
you know if those kind of things happen
that'd be amazing but i i like how
denise said it on set we're going to
make the film that we want to make
period t
real quick how did you do the blue eyes
cgi yeah that was just that was a
digital effect i think there was a
bit of a debate about using lenses or
cgi yeah i did do a lens
fitting i did one in new york too but i
was uh admittedly i was freaked out yeah
i was hoping that we wouldn't have to
use them because it's almost like like
you know like it's like looking through
use them on youtube
no no no well i gotta rap with you guys
but um also really quick especially
because you're both such fashionistas
the costumes in this movie what was it
like to wear those and then did you have
any input
no i'd like to say we had anybody
they you know uh costumes are incredible
they're designed to a t and i think
we're talking about the other night the
fact just that the heart of the world
the harkinans the world of the sardikar
the world of etradis the world of fremen
they're all designed to it
to a texture into a fabric in different
ways and
i can tell you having seen the costume
office in this movie
in the warehouse indiana jones like
effect you had when you walked in the
everyone worked extremely hard on this i
sure did
all right i'll let you guys go so
zendaya for our info who are you wearing
today
well i'm on again today again today and
timothy what are you what are you
wearing there this is a slytherin
sweater from the harry potter
i i got one there too really wouldn't
yeah gryffindor though
slytherin okay
does it pull over yeah
okay slytherin thank you good to know
your house thank you